it's one thing to make the decision it's
another thing to execute the decision
now it didn't take
any analytics experts for doug peterson
to know that he needed to go for two
went down two after scoring a touchdown
late against the ravens and almost
completing what would have been one of
the more impressive comebacks of the
year but there was a problem with
actually getting the play called and
getting the play communicated to the
quarterback here's peterson taking some
responsibility for what went wrong on
that fateful two-point try
great opportunity right there to to
you know score tie the football game
um
you know i can do i can do better as far
as getting the play in and and you know
giving giving our guys a better
opportunity
play call wise too in that situation but
you know credit them made the stop and
uh just a little bit short
the point i made last night he seems
awfully relaxed for a guy that everybody
in philadelphia wants to have fired i'm
impressed i'm impressed by his calm and
i re it really frustrates me because
they still have a fairly new super bowl
trophy yeah i wish eagles fans would be
a little more forgiving here but uh you
know hey he's acknowledging he made a
mistake he's acknowledging that that's
on him and uh it really is impressive
that they made that game as close as it
was but it's depressing for an eagles
fan that they had a chance to to tie it
up and there was some sort of mechanical
issue that kept them from getting the
right play called timely enough for it
to be executed the right way yeah i i
don't i i mean i i i wonder what went on
there or what what exactly he's
specifically talking about you know we
broke down this play a little bit in
football night in america because coach
dungey and i as we were watching the
game live we just went
well wait you that that play
that look was never right to run that
play there was gonna be two guys
unblocked there was a pre-snap motion
you know the old read option where you
stick it in the running backs belly if
the defensive end crashes then you keep
it and go well the defensive end crashed
but they also had an outside linebacker
there as well and i don't know if philly
expected them to be
doing something different schematically
or what it was but at no point was there
a look to go
oh i think this is going to be the look
where he keeps it and runs for a
touchdown i guess that's where i was a a
little so surprised you know in general
especially for a team that
hey the first touchdown of the game they
went for two
you know i just would i would have
thought they have more in the bank as
far as two-point plays and that type of
stuff but the eagles that is the way
they live you know and you know mike i
still look at the eagles and
i have respect for them in a lot of ways
because of doug peterson the way he
carries himself and the way they hang in
there in these games i mean they're not
horrible they've played some really good
damn teams and
uh i i guess i respect that even though
they're in a bad spot right now
i think right now if i had to pick one
of the four teams in the nfc used to win
the dude you're going with them right
yeah me too yeah me too right because
they've been there and done that they've
been the past two years they're
overlooked they're outcasts they're done
it's over and then they find a way to
get it all together late in the season
when everything matters and they get a
chance on thursday night against the
giants to get to two four and one and uh
they still have two games against the
cowboys that they'll have to play and uh
you know it just feels like the cowboys
are moving in the wrong direction the
eagles are kind of rudderless right now
but at some point they're going to find
their way and i think a game like what
they had on sunday when they did show
themselves they can dig out of that hole
they can come back maybe that does give
them a little something going into the
easier part of the schedule after they
they barely lose to the ravens yeah i
mean i think there is something to be
you know take away there you know even
the way they hung in there against
pittsburgh the week before it was a
similar type of thing
they've had a tough schedule
they definitely have and they're a
physical football team and we're still
waiting for some of these offensive
weapons to come back to where
maybe when desean jackson and al shawn
jeffrey get back it won't be just carson
wentz having to be hercules all game
long i mean he's the only thing they got
you know i i again i watched highlight
shows yesterday and people were talking
about bench carson wentz and i want to
go wait bench the best player on their
team what what what i mean he can't do
it all i just don't know what people
expect from the guy i mean we're his
number one target by far is a guy that
nobody's never even heard of and fulgum
i mean nobody so
i don't know where the expectations are
so high there he went
two-point conversion to tie a game
against a baltimore ravens team that is
in a different class than his
philadelphia eagles team and the only
reason the eagles were there and it was
in it was carson wentz so i just wish
people would stop that hate on him and i
wish everybody would just stop the if
they lose we blame the quarterback if
they win we give the quarterback credit
i mean we're just so obsessed with that
right now as football fans it's driving
me crazy
i think part of it too as it relates to
eagles fans and i think this is huge
nature once you get it once you get a
taste of that
that championship life yeah you want it
again right and and you don't want to go
back
to being seven and nine you you you want
it and you don't want anyone else to
have it because you know how good it was
and it drives you crazy every year to
see another team get to do what you did
you want it it just becomes an obsession
and i think that's part of the problem
in philadelphia they're obsessed with
the idea of getting another one now that
they've gotten their first one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports